let me bring in Chris Mannix from Yahoo
Sports let me start there if you're
starting your team you know what you you
know who they are
it's Dirk Nowitzki versus Vince Carter
you're starting your team with who I
mean there's a lot of reasons but a big
they could do with Dirk did I mean a he
was special I mean this is great and I
don't blame Vince for his team's not
winning a championship there's more to
it than that but you know everything
Dirk could do offensively and either one
was a great defensive players you really
look at the offensive end of the floor I
would take Dirk but who changed the the
bigs on the perimeter was it Dirk oh
yeah I mean Dirk I mean you asked any
any yo GM that's been around a long time
there changed the game in ways that I'm
not sure any athlete ever really has I
mean outside of like you know a shack at
the five and with the overwhelming power
but even that you go back to Wilt
Chamberlain when you talking physical
dominance you know that the NBA had
never seen you know a player like like
Dirk do doing what he did I mean I think
that draft man like I got whose draft
like Robert tractor-trailer was like
traded for Dirk I didn't like he was
like the the big that everyone was
looking for at that time I mean they
just weren't seven footers six ten guys
six eleven shooting breeze he has
changed the game and now as we enter
like this generation you've got
porzingis you know changing fives so you
know 20 years ago
Dirk changed the four and today
porzingis and and one or two others
exchanging fives let's look at the top
of the draft here because DeAndre Aiden
doesn't fall into that perimeter
category for a guy who's 7 feet tall
Bagley has range here but how surprised
are you that those are the gonna be the
two top picks in the draft
well first I'm not convinced that that
bag was the guy to I was speaking to to
some sources that are with knowledge of
what Sacramento is doing this morning
and they're torn right now between Luca
dhansak and and Marvin Bagley one thing
you have to remember about Sacramento is
that I mean they've had so much bad PR
over the last you know decade Bukit
dhansak is a really safe pick if they
draft Luca dhansak locally the fans are
going to love it the local press
probably eaten up it you can't discount
that and I think ownership
you know also likes dhansak and that'll
play a role in these coming 24 hours but
you know the the two bigs at the top
with with respect to what they can do on
the perimeter
I think DeAndre Aiden you know I was
talking to a couple of college coaches
about him he has the potential to be a
3-point shooter his form is really good
yeah you have a guy that could shoot
like that it's not a stretch to see you
know no pun intended him to seem spaced
out a little bit more as early as his
first year and become a decent 3-point
shooter give me the guy that has the
fewest question marks I mean 18 taking 8
now the picture because I think he's a
consensus number one you know you know
you ain't a little motor thing I hate
using that stuff because I don't even
know what it means half the time but he
takes C tips and plays off but he
certainly is if you read Pete's analyze
a terrific story on beyond rate and
that's up on Yahoo it's like I mean this
guy you know bounced around so much had
about 150 handlers you know for high
school kids so he's gonna burn some
stuff and and how that's affecting I
don't know but Asians the one with fewer
questions after that so it's daunting
and I don't know what his feeling is I
mean I said somebody described him to me
as you know kind of a souped-up hater
Kalu type you know we always have to go
for Lexie the white International
European comparison but I don't like but
but he's you know you watch him play you
know what drives me crazy dan is like
the last like month Lucas Don cheek has
been kind of picked apart
he went from like two months ago being a
consensus number two to being just sort
of dissected out there and the reason is
because he's been playing games like
he's been playing competitive basketball
for the last month so we're picking him
apart whereas we're getting giddy about
you know the number of three pointers
you know player acts made
the chair or the number of jumpers he
sought over a broom handle like I just
this draft process it always cracks me
up with with what teams care about but I
think Don check out of anybody besides
Dayton as the fewest question marks you
can check out MBA draft show tonight
featuring Chris Mannix Pete thamel Mike
Hopkins and West Wilcox 7:00 Eastern on
Yahoo Sports and Yahoo Sports mobile app
a couple other things here with LeBron
I guess opting out what happens with
Kawhi what happens with Paul George
which which of these three guys who
makes the first move here and then what
happens after that well you know based
on what I hear out of San Antonio I
don't think that happens anytime soon
the message the Spurs like everybody's
called
and everybody's checked in because they
all want to get Kawhi but the message
the Spurs are sending back is look don't
believe everything you read
we think we can resign him but if you
want to make us an offer you know we'll
consider it I mean it's basically
becoming as one GM told me a blind
auction out there so you can make a
bunch of offers and the Spurs will pick
through I mean they are gonna be
methodical with this as they should be I
mean this is a top-five player in the
NBA in his prime that they'll be trading
so I don't think that gets done before
free agency and after that it's gonna be
LeBron now the wild card is if is if
Paul George likes Russell Westbrook in
Oklahoma City a lot more than we think
he does I've been Savin pretty
consistent in saying that I think that
we're really discounting the fact that
he could go back there because the
relationship with Russell is really
strong but if you look at those three
eyes you're talking about LeBron is
probably gonna make the first move and
Paul George is simultaneously or Amelie
after that would be nice just I'm
curious if LeBron goes to the Lakers a
year early or he would wait a year just
to find out what Kawhi does what Paul
George does that do you want to get
there and all of a sudden nobody's
joining you yeah does LeBron want to get
into that scenario it's a reasonable you
know point then I mean he's not going to
play
Brandon Ingram Alonzo ball like he just
not if that's the case I mean does he
try to link up with Houston per year
does he go back to Cleveland for a year
with an understanding that you know do a
one plus one with Cleveland with an
understanding that in the offseason
they'll package Kevin Love and whoever
they draft at number eight to change
things up because equally as sure then
he's not going back to Cleveland that
same team he knows what the ceiling is
for that same team so they'd have to do
something if there's just not a lot of
great options out there for him nothing
that makes as much sense as Miami did in
2010 with that group as Cleveland did in
2014 with their group it's it's not an
ideal market in the summer 25 2018 for
LeBron is there somebody they can draft
that LeBron is gonna go okay alright I
can make I can make this work
yeah but but they're not they're not
gonna do that and for what I'm I'm told
they're not even consulting with LeBron
on this I mean they're making this pick
you know completely independent of
LeBron James I think they'd like it if
Michael Porter Jr slipped down to them
he's one of the most interesting guys in
this draft because there are people that
love him and are trying to move up to
get him and there are teams in that top
10 that are legit terrified of this back
injury I say they're not the change that
the top of it but like number three is
where the action starts I don't think
Atlanta wants that pick I think they
look there they'll auction that off
instead try to put down I report
yesterday that they're I try young and
they don't need to be at 3:00 to draft
ray young so I think they're gonna try
to move back into the top 10 and try to
trade it for a team that wants Luca
dodging there are a bunch of teams that
want Luca dodging so if Sacramento goes
Bagley it's gonna be on I think if they
go Bagley Atlanta traits that pick and
all of a sudden we're off to the races
will you be tweeting the draft picks
before they're announced well right now
the answer is no we'll see what happens
in you know twelve hours
well we who's gonna why why is there
some down here well I mean there's I
think we've we've all kind of a
that's whether it's the the the NBA
partners so to speak have agreed to not
do it I mean I look it's not really a
question of me necessarily I'm hosting
the show it's difficult for me to do it
but it's it's Shawn's it's it's others
that are with us I don't know I'm still
trying to fail put this with I'm still
trying to figure out what the rules are
on this and what we can and can't do on
draft night when you get your haircut on
our show I'm targeting July 29th what
are your thoughts on that so that
whatever that Monday is okay all right
see if we can pencil you in anybody else
getting their head shaved on our show
that day Polly no it's all wide open
okay I just want to make sure so July
29th for Manik so maybe it's the 30th
maybe it's a 30th that's a that's on
Monday
okay if you play in my own Barbara
though if you played Adrienne will
Generale ski a game to 10 who would win
oh I win 10 nothing like I yeah first of
all I mean I've got the size and the
strength and a skill so I would control
that game from start to fish but whoa
Generale ski would break this story
before you would that you had beaten him
without question he would have it at you
know if it's 2-1 and he would have to
gain being over all right give me the
NBA inside I might go Ric Bucher
over you in basketball yeah yeah I'm
basketball
yeah I don't seen I'm sure I think we
have been playing media games I've been
played in the wild but we often time get
together and play media games
Broussard's good Broussard's really good
I think he played college basketball on
some level and sneaky good is Mike wise
formerly of Washington Post yeah yeah
he's a tall tall drink of water there if
I had you against even a Smith
one-on-one I haven't seen even a play
but I mean look you know me then I have
warped confidence you know I just I'll
never bet against myself on those
those games I think I'd kick his ass too
I think I remember seeing Stephen a
shoot in Houston at an NBA Finals and
he's got a you've got an ugly shot well
doesn't it come down at this point into
like the ability to to you know you have
condition like oh yeah I watched that
ridiculous Jimmy Kimmel Ted Cruz game
where you know so those guys look like
they were gassed after two two minutes
yeah like I might just dribble around
and and try to you know get Stephen a to
lose a stamina there and then you know
take them off the dribble right and just
curious sugar all right have fun tonight
okay thanks for joining us and we'll see
you in late July you got that's Chris
Mannix you can check out the NBA draft
show tonight featuring Mannix also Pete
thamel you got Mike Hopkins West Wilcox
7:00 Eastern on Yahoo Sports and Yahoo
Sports mobile app for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]